what's the uh the biggest mistake you've
ever made in your life and how did you
recover
uh i've made a class of mistakes that i
would summarize in the same way uh and i
uh made this class of mistakes
uh and it was obvious to me with these
mistakes we're only in hindsight through
one exercise which is you probably heard
the you know when you're 30 what advice
would you give your 20 year old self
yeah i mean you're 40 like what advice
would you give your 20 your 30 year old
self so if you do that exercise decay by
decade or maybe if you're younger you
can do it in five
really sit down and say
okay you know 2007 what was i doing how
was i feeling 2008 what was i doing how
was i feeling 2009 what was i doing how
was i feeling and at least for me this
remarkable consistency emerged
and that consistency was that uh
everything that i was doing i should
have still done but with less emotion
and especially less anger because i used
to be very angry when i was younger
but especially it's less emotion
life is going to play out the way it's
going to play out some good some bad but
most of it is actually just up to your
interpretation
you're born you have a set of sensory
experiences then you die and how you
choose to interpret those sensory inputs
is up to you and different people to
interpret them in different ways but
really i wish i had done all of the same
things but with less emotion and less
anger
uh like the most celebrated example
would be you know when i was younger i
started a company and the company did
well but i didn't do well so i sued some
of the people involved and it was a good
outcome for me in the end and everything
worked out okay but there was a lot of
angst and a lot of anger and really
today you know what i would do is i
wouldn't go down the angst in the anger
i would have just walked up to the
people and said look this is what
happened this is what i'm going to do
this is how i'm going to do it this is
what's fair this is what's not but i
would have realized that the anger and
the emotion themselves have this huge
consequence just completely unnecessary
so now i'm just trying to learn from
that and to do the same things that i
think are the right thing to do
but to do them without anger and to do
them with a very long-term point of view
so i think if you take a very long-term
point of view and if you take the
emotion out of it then uh i wouldn't
consider those things mistakes anymore
um other than that i mean
there was a
you know the perspective i like to adopt
is that everything that i did and
everything that was done to me um and
you know there's some
impossible separate combination
brought me to this exact moment here
today talking to you
and uh this is a good moment so it's a
great moment whatever
yeah so whatever set of circumstances
conspired to bring us here
we're good because here i am
was there a moment you would say when
you realized that you could control how
you interpreted i mean i think one of
the problems that a lot of people have
is they don't recognize that they can
control not what happens to them per se
but how they respond and how they
interpret
a situation
i think everyone knows it's possible and
the reason they know it's possible is
there's a great osho lecture that he
calls the title the attraction of drugs
is spiritual and he talks about why do
people do drugs everything from alcohol
psychedelics to cannabis so you name it
and they're doing it to control their
mental state and they're doing it to
control how they react and sometimes
it's worse and sometimes it's better but
some people drink because then they
don't care as much or they their pot
heads because they can zone out or they
do psychedelics so they can feel you
know very present or connected to nature
what have you but the attraction of
drugs is spiritual so to some extent we
already know that we can control our
internal state we just use external
bioactive substances to do it
and now there are a lot more techniques
that are out there the public domain
many of them dug up from uh older times
but uh you know these range from
cognitive therapy and behavioral
psychology to meditation to taking long
walks in nature you can control your
mental state it's just we're used to
doing it by hacking our external
circumstances to then come back around
and control our mental state
um and uh for example sitting on a on a
there's a famous line that says that uh
all of man's problems arise because he
can't sit by himself in a room for 30
minutes obviously yeah
yeah exactly so uh you know if a man or
woman can sit by themselves on a cushion
for 30 minutes and that's hard it's
really hard to do that's meditation
you are essentially struggling with and
controlling your internal state and the
first thing the first thing to realize
is that you can actually observe your
mental state so just the the the
advantage of meditation is not that
you're only going to gain a superpower
to control your internal state it's that
you will recognize just how out of
control your mind is it is like a monkey
flinging feces that's running around the
room making trouble shouting breaking
things it's completely uncontrollable
it's an out of control mad person
and you have to see this mad creature in
operation before you feel a certain
distaste towards it and you start
separating yourself from it and in that
separation is liberation when you
realize that oh i don't want to be that
person
why am i so out of control just that
awareness alone calms you down
um so there are there are many
techniques one can use another one for
example that
i think a lot of smart people say is if
if you're angry about something or if
you get an unhappy email and you want to
respond don't respond for 24 hours right
what does that do it just your you calm
down your the emotions subside the
hormones go down and your mental in a
better mental state 24 hours later so i
think people already know this um but we
just don't act on it because socially
we're not conditioned to act on it
socially we're told
go work out go look good
because that's a multiplayer competitive
game other people can see if i'm doing a
good job or not or we're told go make
money
go buy a big house again external
multiplayer competitive game but when it
comes to
learn to be happy train yourself to be
happy completely internal
no external progress no external
validation 100 you're competing against
yourself single player game
uh and we're such social creatures we're
more like bees or ants that we're
externally programmed and driven
that we just don't know how to play and
win at these single player games anymore
we compete purely on multiplayer games
but the reality is life is a single
player game you're born alone you're
gonna die alone all your interpretations
are alone all your memories are alone
and you're gone three generations nobody
cares before you showed up nobody cared
it's all single player i think buffett
has a great example of that when he
gives the do you want to be the world's
best lover and known as the worst or the
world's worst lover and known as the
best in reference to an inner or
external scorecard
exactly right i mean all the real
scorecards are internal
and the sad thing is you know we sit
there like jealousy jealousy was a very
hard emotion for me to overcome uh when
i was young i had a lot of jealousy in
me
and by and by you know i i i learned to
get rid of it and it still crops up
every now and then but it's such a
poisonous emotion because at the end of
the day you're no better off you're
unhappier and the person you're jealous
of is still successful or good looking
or whatever they are but the the real
breakthrough was for me was when i
realized at a personal fundamental level
i mean i the problem with these kinds of
podcasts is i can give glib answers all
day long but you have to discover your
own personal answer because your
personal answers will be different than
mine and i'll speak to you but the one
that i discovered that spoke to me was
the day i realized that all these people
that i was jealous of i couldn't just
cherry-pick and choose little aspects of
their life i couldn't say i want his
body i want her money i want his
personality you have to be that person
do you want to actually be that person
with all of their reactions their
desires their family their happiness
level their outlook on life their
self-image and if you're not willing to
do a wholesale 24 700 swap with who that
person is then there's no point in being
jealous
i think that's great
once i came to that realization jealousy
sort of faded away because i don't want
to be anybody else i'm perfectly happy
being me
and by the way even that is under
control to be happy being
it's just there's no social rewards for
it but there's a lot of internal rewards
yeah there's it's almost anti-social
rewards because when you're when you're
working on your inner stuff
people don't love that
it's not they don't dislike it your
friends of course support you but
they're not getting anything out of it
uh and even when i look at my own
uh peer group and to the extent that
they're working on themselves and and
everyone in their 40s at some level is
most ever engaged in grouped activities
hey let's do a group meditation hey
let's do this group event hey let's go
to this group lecture
and i keep coming back to this one line
that i read like everything i just read
but um which was said only the
individual transcends nobody reaches
enlightenment or or or internal
happiness or does serious internal work
in group settings
uh it is a very lonely kind of task
so to some extent i think that people
who are constantly looking for social
affirmation
in their internal work aren't that
serious about it but and it's fine i'm
not judging but just they're craving
more social interaction then they're
really craving internal work
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
you